tell me about your scene tonight darling  camp dear it's just about the designs -  the sketches how did you come up with  these lines I mean these girls to dress  how can you stop fantasizing I mean look  at Liz oh she is divine look at Rita she  is everything with her old Hollywood Hey  serving we still forgot us I mean it's  so extra tonight I just can't believe  with the camp love banana winter started  the carpet off with pink feathers just  like you then Lady gaga did for costume  changes then Billy Porter got carried in  I mean the night has just been so  dramatic is this extra what is camp to  you Rita it's all about your  individuality it's about being free  being yourself being vibrant and being  extra thank you guys for stopping  congratulations  [Music]